are we ready yet
yeah we're all good to go thanks chair
great okay
it is now 5 30 to order everyone for
this meeting
of the council the 25th of february 2021
good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the press and
public i welcome you to this meeting of
the council
prior to this meeting all participants
have previously checked that they can be
heard
and seen and can see and hear other
members
it is vital that you can be heard and it
is preferred that cameras are kept on
throughout the meeting to double check
this and to introduce everyone who is
present at this remote meeting i would
kindly ask that i confirm your
attendance
and your role or job title when i say
your name
i shall now go through a list for this
evening
counselor album uh here chair
a cabinet member for operational
services
and award councillor for eastcliff
ramsgate
excellent councillor ara good evening
chair
yeah what counselor for central harbour
ward in ramsgate
councillor ashby shadow leader and wool
councillor for westbrook
thank you councillor bailey good evening
councillor for ward council of the
viking ward thank you
thank you councillor bambridge
i'm councillor for westgate on c thank
you
thank you counsellor jill dave
hey chair um councillor for bradstow
award
and shadow portfolio holder for housing
thank you councillor robert bayford
evening chair i'm chair of ovue and
scrutiny and broadcaster for kingsgate
thank you
thank you councillor boyd good evening
chair and to everyone
i'm the counsellor for garland ward
thank you councillor braidwood
councillor braidwood i shall come back
later
councillor coleman cook
here chair um vice chair of planning
and world councillor for burchington
north
thank you very much councillor
christendom
chair east cliff ward ramsgate
councillor curry
good evening chair um vice chair of
overview and scrutiny and world
councillor for cliftonville west
thank you councillor day
councillor day i shall come back
councillor dennis evening chair
councillor for garland ward
thank you counselor dexter
evening chairman councillor for some
petersburg
councillor duckworth good evening chair
cabinet member for estates and economic
development dane valley ward
councillor everett good evening chair uh
wall councillor for newington and leader
of the council
thank you councillor farrons uh good
evening
i'm samson ward councillor
thank you councillor fellows yeah
evening chair i'm the councillor for
merchants himself
thank you council again um evening
councillor for cliftonville east
thank you councillor ghana good evening
i'm councillor phil peters i'm leader of
the green group
and i'm also now chair of governance and
audit committee
thank you councillor greene um
councillor greene
ward councillor for nether courts in
southward
thank you councillor gregory evening
councillor for samson ward
thank you councillor hart
evening chair uh council of athanic
villages
thank you councillor hopkinson
for samosa's monster fury award thank
you
councillor huxley hello chair i'm a
councillor for east gift walden ramsgate
thank you councillor keem good evening
chair councillor for cliftonville west
thank you councillor cop leaving chair
shallow cabinet member for
operational services and counsellor for
birchman south
thank you councillor pat moore
evening chair councillor forcer moses
montefiore reward
thank you councillor paul moore good
evening chair
award councillor for beacon ward thank
you council ovendom
member for nevercall councillor parsons
thank you councillor linda piper
apologies chair apologizing
received and accepted thank you and i
took it you're with us councillor piper
castle stewart piper yes good evening mr
chairman yes i'm here uh leader of the
planet independence
group and general all around nuisance
uh i'm not gonna say anything right now
councillor potts
councillor potts apologies chair she
will be arriving late
right okay apologies accepted
in lou councillor pugh
evening chair councillor pew uh board
member for fanuc villages and
shadow deputy leader thank you
councilloraticum
hitch uh good evening councillor for
cliffs and
thank you councillor roth good evening a
beacon ward councillor
thank you councillor rogers
good evening chair um world councillor
for cliffs and pedwell
villages thank you councillor roseki
evening chair councillor for northwood
and deputy leader of the planet
thank you councillor david saunders
good evening chair viking ward
councillor shadow cabinet member
for finance administration and community
wealth building
thank you very much councillor maeve
[Music]
you might find you've got a little bit
of trouble with feedback you might want
to look at it
councillor scoby evening chair president
uh councillor for cliftonville west
thank you councillor scott
good evening chair award councillor for
westgate on c
thank you councillor shrub here chair
councillor for cliftonville east
thank you councillor tomlinson okay
rincher
councillor for westbrook and chairman of
the planning committee
thank you councillor towning evening
councillor for
clifton released thank you councillor
whitehead
president chair uh councillor for
margate central
deputy leader and cabinet member for
housing
and safer communities quite so
councillor
evening chair councillor for central
harbour in ramsgate
thank you councillor wright good evening
chair
vice chairman and ward councillor for
burchington south
and finally councillor yates good
evening chair
uh margaret central ward and cabinet
member for finance administration and
community wealth building
thank you i'll just return to see if
councillor braidwood is with us
councillor braidwood apologies mr
chairman
he's offered apologies he's not just
absent he's has apologized
councillor day do i have councillor day
i don't have any apologies therefore i
shall mark him as absent
moving on to officers in attendance we
have the chief executive miss homer
the deputy chief executive mr willis the
director of operational services mr
waite
the director of law and democracy ms
culligan and the committee services
manager mr hughes
now then as we go through the meeting if
you have any technical difficulties
during meeting then please contact
one of the democratic services officers
on the call who will attempt to assist
you
i would ask participants when you are
not speaking please mute your microphone
this minimizes background noise and will
help everyone
listening to the proceedings microphones
must be
only be on if participant has been
granted permission to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
very briefly indicate on the chat to the
right side
of the screen and i will then make a
note and come back to you once the
person speaking has finished
with respect to webcasting or
proceedings please note this meeting is
being live streamed for members of the
public
except for any item of business where
exempt or confidential
information is considered following the
exclusion of the press and public from
the meeting
this meeting is also being recorded and
will be subsequently broadcast on the
internet with the restriction respect a
restriction of use of mobile phones
would everyone present please
ensure their mobile phones are turned to
silent
and they are not used to make or receive
phone calls whilst the meeting is in
progress
do not turn your phone off as it will
make it harder for democratic services
to contact you should they need to
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting other business ensure that
you're in a quiet room
free from distractions for the duration
of the meeting
now then agenda item one therefore
apologies for absence
uh a path from councillor day i've not
received any apologies for this evening
group leaders do you have any apologies
you wish to reassert
i don't think so i've gone through a
thorough list
moving therefore onto a gender item two
minutes of the meeting held on the 9th
of july 2020.
i move that the mints of the meeting or
the council held on 11th of february
2021 be approved and signed
as a correct record with the vice
chairman please second
second like mr chairman
unless anyone objects the minute i will
take them as agreed
thank you therefore moving on to agenda
item
three announcements i am very sorry
to announce and i know a good few of us
are already aware of this but sorry to
announce
the recent passing of councillor peter
campbell
councillor campbell first became a
senate district councillor in 2007
and served the central harbour ward in
ramsgate for 14 years
i'd ask members to pause for a minute
silence in respect of councillor
campbell
thank you everyone now i do have a list
of members
who would like to say a few words about
council campbell
for my part i shall very much miss
councillor campbell
in my time here at sonic council i have
been chairman of the governance and
order committee which as some of you
know
is quite a demanding committee but i
could always rely on peter
to have not only thoroughly read his
paperwork but to be ready with questions
and observations
important to the business he could
unravel issues which could
only come from a full understanding of
what was going on
a truly great and committed councillor i
call him councillor everett
leader of the council yes thank you
chair and uh i have to say this is
probably the saddest task that i've had
as a counselor
and i know that i speak for many of us
when i say that i've personally lost a
good friend
as well as an outstanding colleague the
fact that we knew this day was coming
doesn't make it any easier
but at least it allowed us to let peter
know
the respect and affection with which he
was regarded across the council
and i know that he did appreciate that
the other consolation that we should
take tonight
is that peter loved being a counsellor
and he got to do it for 14 years
he took enormous pride and satisfaction
in representing ramsgate and central
harbour in particular
in fact he was still working away on
residents behalf from the hospice
he was in on the day before he died
his commitment to this council since
2007
and to ramsgate town council was
extraordinary
if you look on the council website it's
a statistical fact
that he attended far more meetings than
anyone else but more importantly
as you've alluded to he'd always done
his homework and he always had something
to contribute
and quite often that would be a joke to
lighten the mood
because he was quite a funny man and i
still remember the
leaflet that he produced in central
harbour ward in 2011 before the election
in which he introduced the labor
candidates karina huxley
and mary dwyer as she then was as his
new assistants
which perhaps wasn't very appropriate
but being peter he got away with it
away from central harbour he didn't want
to be a leader
but he had authority because he usually
knew what he was talking about
and he was always willing to share his
knowledge and experience
including with me so i have
two bites of this because i've obviously
referred to it in my leaders speech and
i know lots of other people wish to
speak
to but just to conclude our thoughts
must be with mitzi his partner
and his wider family but this council
will miss him deeply
and me more than most and i know that he
won't be forgotten by any of us
who had the good fortune to work with
him
thank you very much indeed councillor
everett can i turn to
councillor pugh next uh to say a few
words councillor pugh
thank you chair um i mean as as i think
everyone was i was incredibly saddened
to hear of
um of the passing of councillor campbell
i have uh very fond memories as a newly
elected
member in 2018 um in a bit of a baptism
of fire
as we first week we voted down the local
plan
but i remember um being put on the
governance and order committee
and sitting next to peter on on many an
occasion and
the the wisdom and and just the energy
that he had and and as
the leader has said he was a counselor
for such a long time but
that experience really shined through
and and i consider myself very lucky
that
although i was only on the governance
and order committee with him for a short
period
up until the 2019 elections you know
everything that i learned from him i'll
always remember
because you know the way in which he
conducted himself and the way in which
he
scrutinized his counsel and the
questions that he raised and
you know very often and i was
particularly in a way and i'm
glad to admit it intimidated by
councillor campbell and the knowledge
that he had
but one thing that i'll always remember
is that you know he was always
always willing to kind of have a bit of
a chuckle and you know and we were able
to kind of laugh sometimes
and particularly as a new counselor you
know very intimidated by
the council and and members and not
really
knowing you know when i should speak and
my voice and stuff like that he was
always
very encouraging um and you know and i
think him and councillor
uh who was councillor messenger carol
partinson at the time were a real force
to be reckoned with
particularly in holding to account uh
the ukip chair of that
of that committee um so i will i will
remember him fondly and i think he's the
real loss
uh to all residents of dannet because i
think he did such a
stellar job and and if i can one day be
as good a counselor as him then
i think i would have done all right
thank you very much indeed for that
council of pew
councillor ara
councillor ara thank you chair yes
i was extremely honored to be elected as
the award counselor for central harbor
in brumsgate
alongside my fellow counselor peter
campbell and becky wing
in 2019 peter was a very state talking
counselor
he was extremely popular among the
people of ramsgate
and i have enjoyed every single minute
that i spent with him
either campaigning or going through
caseworks
and i will always remember him for this
i have learnt so much from him
there is an english expression that says
i stand upon the shoulders of giants
peter was one of my giants my deepest
condolences
go out to his wife mitzi and to his
family
may he rest in peace thank you thank you
councillor
councillor tomlinson uh thank you chair
and thank you for allowing me just to
say
a few words um a lot has already been
stated by
other members and i'm sure there is more
to come
i met peter at a social function um
i can't really recall how many years ago
but it's got to be about 20 years ago
in ramsgate before he became a
councillor
many people were aware that i was
involved in organizing
carnegie rents over here in margate and
we were at a carnival event
peter wanted to get involved in ramsgate
committees and so on um straight away
i started to like peter his comments he
said who he was what he wanted to do
and a friendship built up over many
years
and as i said it's already been said um
he he was straight talking uh he
knew what he wanted to talk about there
wasn't a committee meeting that went by
where he wasn't or didn't say something
and this is a great loss when i heard
and i
i think we've all seen over a number of
years how
he has deteriorated
which is very very sad and he's in peace
now
a great friend myself and my other half
and one of the biggest things i think
with peter
we all do things in life what peter did
was wonderful for ramsgate but he didn't
shout about it
and i think that is quite something and
uh again i wish his family
our elthorpes thank you chairman thank
you very much councillor thomason
councillor whitehead
thank you chair
um i've been lucky enough to have some
exceptional teachers
one my history teacher prepared me very
well for life and for this role
in everything he talked about the
importance of facts and opinions
a primary and secondary and tertiary
sources
and how to know if the information you
have is accurate
how to know if you can trust in it how
to cross-reference
and challenge yourself and others in
terms of your understanding and
knowledge
i've long used those skills in theory
counselor campbell taught me how to use
them in practice
all of us in the chamber know how good
he was
know how well and how thoroughly he did
his research
do you know how and when's challenged
and that he challenged anyone regardless
of party
if he thought it was the right thing to
do
i only knew peter for a few years but he
knew me as a new
and scared counsellor as a new and
scared
shadow cabinet member and eventually has
a new
equally scared and determined deputy
leader within that time
and his advice was always the same
do your research find the facts
challenge who you need to when you need
to
and don't be afraid when you're doing it
or if you can't manage that
don't look afraid i'm not good with
public grief
but we have all lost a strong formidable
and committed counsellor
and i'm still trying to imagine the
chamber
without his voice interjecting to
deliberately ask me an
entertainingly difficult question about
paragraph 76 sub section 2 in the third
appendix
and i can't imagine it
and i don't want to
because the chamber will be so much
sadder without him
and without his deliberate conscientious
and above all entertaining scrutiny
counselor campbell was to the very core
of him the essence of good scrutiny
he challenged clearly he challenged well
and he challenged anyone he needed to
he challenged me and he taught me how to
be a better counsellor
i don't think he'd want me to end on a
sad note and i'm trying not to
so i'm going to talk about the legacy he
left
so here's to those who know how to
challenge effectively
may we know them may we be thankful to
have known them
and in memory of councillor campbell may
we be them
thank you thank you very much indeed
counselor
um white said i think all of us very
moved by the emotions
you feel this evening thank you very
much indeed for that
counselor wing
uh yes thank you chair uh such a sad
time in ramsgate we seem to have lost
too many of our
community champions this year and peter
was amongst the very best of them
uh a committed family man dog lover
obviously was three
three three dogs that he loved so much
and one who loved his role as a
counsellor
he performed his role with determination
commitment and
most importantly concern for residents
and he did all this with a sense of
humor
he will be missed by so many and i send
much love
to mitzi and his family and close
friends
councillor ira and myself are determined
to try and do our best for the people of
central harbor without
uh peter
a sign of the man and his commitment to
it was he was still
sharing emails not only with i believe
other councillors but also with myself
and one that left me close to tears and
that was just a matter of eight or nine
hours before before before the
the colossus of a man died uh i'd he's
going to be a hard
set of boots to feel i think in central
uh but we'll keep trying to do
what we can in central harbor in in
peter's memory
and we'll put party differences aside to
make sure we try and do that
thank you thank you very much indeed
councillor wing
councillor pat moore
councillor pat moore i'm trying to
thank you uh i'd just like to say
that i've known peter for a long time
not very well to start with but i've
known you
like make about 20 years and may
say because they frequented the same pub
and then he had long blonde hair brushed
back
do you remember that nick and
it was a very social socialist
in that pub it talked to anybody
about labor my son used to
have frequent chats with him about
labour and
all its stamps for and
i remember him and i became to admire
him
for his wit and wisdom
we shared cars uh when we were going to
uh meetings at tdc
and rtc and uh
we've chatted quite a bit and i found
he was a very brave man placing whatever
he had to
with courage and he also liked a joke
i can he told me once when we were
coming back from
tdc about when he was a young man and he
lived in london
and he was all booted and salted dressed
up smartly dressed shoes polished
and he was walking over i think it was a
canal bridge
and there was some boys at the top
youths shouting
at men on boats and
throwing stones as i presume and
he said they ran off the guys from the
boats came up behind him
grabbed him and threw him in the river
you know that was
and he still thought it was very funny
so did i
and another story about
peter i would like to joke
uh we were in the council chamber and
uh a counselor from across the chamber
was asking about something and it had to
have a number
they said you've got to give us a number
for this and he said oh
i don't know so peter said this isn't
the number
but i know he did it and he said
oh that's a b two three four
so he said oh thank you very much abby
two three four
when we finished the meeting and we're
driving home
mary king was in the car as well and she
said oh you are clever peter remembering
that number
he said no i made it up
that just typifies what he's like
and you know i became to be
very fond of him and uh i once said to
him
a politician is not that far apart
from a stand-up comedian and he was both
thank you thank you very much indeed
councillor moore and that's marvelous to
have here a couple of jokes on behalf of
peter
uh councillor roth
er thank you chair uh councillor
campbell he was a truly a unique
counselor and i think many people
know him agree with that and i first met
him in 2007
when he helped to bring love music had
racism to
ramsgate and also he helped to bring all
the event organizer
together in ramsgate where we set up
ramsgate event organizer group
to make sure all events and drums get
not clash on each other's
and they all help each other to set up
or get
all the events and and often we meet up
accidentally on my walk and we end up
having a coffee
as i elected as a counselor he give me
two
advice and that your advice
will benefit anybody who would like to
become a counselor one day
the first one was he said
you go out and do what you do
people agree with your politic they
already agree with what you are doing
try to get the people don't agree with
your politic
agree with what you are doing and that
is
hard for anybody to try to do that and
peter managed to do that people wasn't
agree with his politic
they would agree with what he was doing
in a community
and as second one uh was he said
make sure when you are out there
that try to um
first do all the training if you can
attend if you can
attended training get the slide from the
officer
and go introduce yourself face to face
to them
as a new lead counselor then tomorrow
when you email them
they know who you are and who they speak
to that your advice
a state is a legacy in my mind and i
will pass it to anybody you wish one day
to become a counselor
thank you thank you very much indeed
councilwolf and of course i think all of
us can see the wisdom
in that counselor scoby
thank you chair um i first bumped into
peter in about 2006 when we were having
a training course for potential new
counsellors
um peter reminded me very much of the
harry enfield character that's not how
you do it
because he seemed to have an answer for
everything
however my first impressions were very
very wrong
because um his mastery of a brief
and how he always managed to do
the job with diligence but tremendous
humor when i became chair of the labour
group
i used to meet with peter and
rick and various other people outside
various cafes
in ramsgate so they could put me right
because of course being a margate person
i didn't know anything about ramsgate
so it's with great sadness that
i'm going to miss those coffee with
peter and mitzi
and his three lovely dogs and i
i i hope the the the family will enjoy
uh a celebration of his life uh when
this
covi nuisance lets us do so thank you
thank you councillor scoby and last on
my list i have counselor album
counselor alvin yeah thank you chair
um i haven't got anything written
written down and
i'm not as eloquent as some of our
previous speakers about
peter um i've known peter
as an officer of the council uh when he
was first the councillor
and because you should come into the
planning office on a regular basis
and um and being a couple of old bald
london boys
as we were are still
um we got on pretty pretty pretty well
and we had a similar
sense of humor and um it was
always a pleasure and since being
elected as
a counselor and i used to give peter
lifts home from
meetings and uh and we'd have a laugh
about whatever it was about what
somebody
said or they got wrong at the meeting
and stuff like that
but um everybody said everything about
peter but i just want to say
um from one old london geyser
to peter i'm gonna miss you mate
thank you very much indeed counselor
album is there anybody i've missed
anybody remaining who'd like to speak
well councillors i think really it says
it all
um we've lost i've got an excellent
colleague and an excellent friend
we'll miss him from the chamber um and i
think the sheer sentiment expressed
tonight
says all so thank you very much
moving on to agenda item four
declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
this evening
i haven't had any indications and i can
see from anybody
so no moving on to agenda item five
there for petitions
uh gender item five a park avenue
broadcast petition
the report backed council now this is
for information only what members please
note the cabinet response the petition
is detailed in the report
i call upon the leader council everett
for an update here which i believe he
has for us
counselor everett yes thank you chair um
i just want you to put into the record
um and note that an appeal has been
lodged against the enforcement action
which is referenced in the report
which is in accordance with proper
process and just to reassure residents
that
the council remains well aware of the
level of public interest in this matter
and our actions will continue to reflect
that
just a bit of an update yes thank you
very much indeed thank you for that
uh therefore moving on to agenda item
six questions from the press and public
i would say first of
all just to make members of the public
aware
democratic services can assist you in
crafting your question
if you are unsure of the appropriate
wording
uh this is for future use of course if
you would like any assistance please
look at the councils
speaking at council meetings webpage
or contact democratic services team who
will be happy to help
now one question has been received from
the public for us
this evening uh in accordance council
procedure rule number 13
please note that only the questioner and
respondent are permitted to speak
on the question and that if the
questioner is not present at this
meeting
their question cannot be put but we
reply to in writing
therefore gender item 6a question number
one from a member of the public
regarding grants and developer
contribution
i will i'm pleased to welcome miss
austin to the meeting
could the questioner please turn on
their microphone state the name
of the cabinet member to whom their
question is to be put and read out the
exact wording of the question
that they submitted to the council ms
austin are you there
i'm here thank you chair um i believe my
question is directed at the leader and
it's as follows
as council budgets tighten external
funding and investment become
increasingly important
what strategies is tdc adopting to
maximize environmental and social
investment from developers
monitor and access grant funding
opportunities
and nurture mutually supportive
partnerships with community groups
who can often access specific funding
streams that will benefit our
communities
thank you thank you miss austin i'll
pull up on the leader to respond
yeah good evening miss austin thank you
thank you for your question and
congratulations on your
ingenuity and fitting in um so much into
the 50 words allowed at the moment
i'm going to give you a very long answer
um so i warn members about that
um first of all i welcome your
recognition that the council budget
continues to be a challenging exercise
drawing on all our skills of both
members and officers to continue to
provide services and retain aspiration
to pursue other positive opportunities
for our residents
i also want to recognise the
contribution that residents make to our
annual survey because those views are
important
in helping the council understand their
priorities
i'm going to approach your question in
three sections developer contributions
grant funding and community groups
developer contributions the local plan
sets out a strategic approach to
contributions from developers and house
builders
and sets out requirements for the
provision of social and environmental
measures
in new development for example education
health open space
landscaping and tree planting water and
energy efficiency
and biodiversity net gain we monitor the
collection and use of all financial and
other contributions and we publish
agreements known as section 106
agreements
in particular in addition we've
succeeded in achieving the following
um 49 000 pounds for affordable housing
uh contributions utilized on bringing
forward homes for affordable housing
retal house and piermont hall 600
000 grant awarded to broadstairs and
some peter's council to bring forward
those properties refurbishment 136 000
for broadstairs playground refurbishment
there's a 49 million pound bid in for
the
to the major road network for a major
road network improvement
um homes england grant funding for new
build phases
um of 860 000.
um there's 666 000 from
celeb money is utilized on the
renovation of two properties in the
intervention area
and there are grant funded programs for
tackling rogue landlords and cold homes
and to employ a home energy officer to
advise residents about available ground
funding
we have the largest disability uh
facilities grant program in kent at
three million annually
and a total of 1.35 million
uh has been received for rise funding
across a range of initiatives for
homeless people
that's a co-design product process
involving the district council
mhclg and local voluntary sector and
community groups
so just some of the grant funded
projects for recent years
ramsgate flood and coast protection
scheme nine hundred thousand
um the uh dolby square scheme 1.9
million from the heritage lottery fund
1.378 million from homes england for the
affordable homes program
527 000 from the forestry commission for
the fanuc community forest
324 000 from the environment agency for
the apple bay sea wall
and 162 000 initially for the margate
town fund
and obviously there's a bid into the
margate town deal with 29 million
um there's another 750 000 from
mhclg uh further funding in relation to
the townsville to renovate a key
building which
you probably know has already been
brought forward there's 2.7 million for
the future high street fund
there's heritage action zone five year
joint program working with historic
england and key community groups
uh in ramsgate there's a high street
heritage action zone
uh scheme uh currently in discussion
with historic england
uh there's 18 million pounds with a
public investment including a 5 million
heritage
heritage lotteries fund grant for
dreamland and of course a substantial
amount of money for fanec parkway
station
and in terms of community groups
obviously ellington park is a good
example
uh 1.643 from the heritage million from
the heritage
lottery fund in terms of other projects
we've recently worked with rise up
cleanup on a project to tackle the
complicated issues we face with litter
on our beaches
exploring a variety of initiatives one
of these is the introduction of some new
litter bag dispensers around the coast
in margate
these are similar to the ticks back dog
waste dispensers we have in place
already
part funded by tdc but mainly crowd
funded by the community group
we help with the agreements in the
installation and they will keep them
stuck with bags
this is the model for the type of
project we'll be looking to expand in
other areas of the district with local
groups
we're exploring ways to work more
closely with our coastal businesses this
summer to support them
also to have their assistance in
spreading messages to our visitors
our climate change officer is looking to
external grant funding to help us
achieve our targets and deliver on our
climate action plan
a number of funding bids have already
been submitted the open spaces team and
climate
change officer are working with local
communities and groups on projects that
will improve our tree canopy cover
and biodiversity across the district
over the years we've worked with a
number of community groups to try and
find solutions to ongoing problems
related to waste recycling and other
public realm issues
the team worked with developers to try
and ensure that these common problems
are designed out in the future
historically we've worked with a variety
of community groups across statistics
to support beach clean litter-picking
activities through the giving out of
equipment and health and safety advice
and this was externally funded through
our work as part of the kent resource
partnership we've benefited from funding
which has enabled waste related
communications and behavior change
projects an example is the food waste
campaign
giving out free caddies and bin liners
which we ran
which was funded by rap and saw an 11
increase in food recycling our education
enforcement officer is and will continue
working to support a number of community
groups and local schools
and we're exploring delivering
chargeable aqa
accredited training courses for a
variety of environmental issues in the
next year
to support local projects so there's
quite a lot going on
thank you chair thank you very much
indeed castle
that was very very thorough miss austin
um
i saw you busy trying to take all that
down with your pen
um you can catch up with it uh on
youtube um
it's released just in case you missed it
thank you very much indeed moving on to
agenda item
7 we have questions from members of the
council two questions have been received
from members of the council for this
evening agenda item 7a
question number one from remember
regarding hedgerow cutting
i call upon councillor wing council wing
are you there
thank you chair i believe my question is
to councillor alban
uh they keep being directed at you it's
just the top of the topic
i'm afraid councillor alban my question
is can we ensure that pre-planning is
undertaken to ensure
none of our hedgerows bushes and trees
are cut in any way during the nesting
season for birds and other wildlife
that is applying section 1 of the
wildlife and countryside act of 1981.
thank you very much councillor wing
castle alban
yes thank you chair it wouldn't be the
same without getting a question from
councillor wing
and uh i was tempted just to give the
short answer
of yes but i wouldn't disrespect her
in that in that way so i will read out i
will read out the full answer
the breeding season for birds is not
definitive
and there are exceptions the rspb
guidance states that nesting season is
generally between the 1st of march and
the 31st of august
during this time we will not be cutting
hedgerows
or trees the only exception
to this is when there is excuse me
when there is an urgent public health
and safety concern
and or the council is served and noticed
by
kent county council to carry out urgent
works
on the highway the open spaces team
has in place procedures for cutting of
trees and hedges
with respect to the bird life at all
times
sorry at all times of the year for this
reason
a process for checking that there are
no nest presence is followed using
infrared cameras
over a period of time to ensure no
disturbance takes place
the team also visually check and will
avoid areas
where nests are present where it is safe
to do so even when carrying out
urgent works thank you chair thank you
very much indeed castle alvin
councillor williams you have a
supplementary uh yes i'd just like to
say
i would like to thank the the teams that
actually come out and do the hedge
cutting because they do
an absolutely fabulous job and i know
there are so many hedges to cut
there's never been a complaint about the
work that the guys actually do
so just thank the team for me thank you
thank you very much indeed uh thank you
agenda item 7b
question number two from a member
regarding housing i call upon councillor
ghana
catholic are you there i am i'm here
thank you chair
um yes since agreeing a new local plan
pathanic last year
we've learned that in 2020 planet
achieved 55
delivery of housing requirement for the
area meaning that
um we haven't met the or the housing
delivery test itself hasn't been met in
planet and we're now there now is a
presumption in favor of sustainable
development when deciding planning
applications
um what action is being taken to improve
this situation
to ensure it is met as soon as possible
and i think that's for the leader
thank you councillor garner and your
preamble to the question was noted
i call upon the leader to respond thank
you chair thank you councillor ghana for
the question members will be delighted
to know that this answer isn't as long
as the last one
um as it's a bit of a strange issue
really because the council can't control
the rate of house building except in
relation to its own
house building program and that's
primarily a matter for the market and
what developers decide to do
all the council can do is seek to create
the right environment to support new
house building which of course is what
we do
the council's published housing
deliberately housing delivery test
action plan
sets out a wide range of actions and
commitments to support house building
the council has already taken most of
the actions recommended by
mhclg and is implementing others
the actions include refining our
development monitoring processes
so that we can better understand delays
in development on site
supporting including financial in the
delivery of fanuc parkway station and
improved travel times from ashford
international station
to improve market perception of the
district for both housing and economic
development
exploring the establishment of a
council-owned housing company
and supporting infrastructure-based
funding bids to government
um to the housing infrastructure fund
local growth fund main road
network funding to improve viability and
deliver key infrastructure
this also includes participation in the
joint kent and medway proposal to the
government
known as the kent deal but
infrastructure provision in kent
to help support good growth the action
plan was based on significant research
into the local housing market and has
been commended by the planning advisory
service
it's currently being updated the council
employs two housing strategy officers
whose role includes supporting local
developers and house builders
to bring their sites forward in addition
the cabinet has recently established a
cabinet advisory group for housing
issues
and we'll be discussing housing supply
and detail at its next meeting
and just to conclude of course the
public often doesn't like to see sites
coming forward
even when they've been allocated in the
local plan but as we can see here
if they don't proceed the effect can be
the opposite of what is desired because
the government will intervene
and in fact it makes unplanned
development more likely
so it's a bit of a difficult one for the
council um
it's unfortunate that the the government
has intervened in this way but it's not
entirely something under our control
thank you very much councillor everest
council garner do you have a
supplementary question
um no i just like to thank thank the
leader for that um
for that um full answer to the question
um
and i look forward to seeing the um
updated action plan
um when it's published thank you thank
you counselor ghana
moving therefore on to agenda item eight
having completed our questions we have a
motion on notice this evening
uh just the one note has been received
in accordance with council procedure
rule number three
agenda item eight a note of motion
universal
credit uplift payments i call upon the
leader councillor everett
yes apologies members you're gonna get a
bit sick of the sound of my voice this
evening but
um there we are um so the motion says
than it has the highest number of
universal credit claimants in kent more
than eighteen
thousand nearly a quarter of the
eligible population
and an increase of almost two-thirds
over the last year
due to the impacts of kovid 19 on our
local economy
a third of these residents are in work
but recorded unemployment is up 80
since march 2020 and now afflicts one in
10 of the working age population
one in eight households is in fuel
poverty
last march the chancellor announced a 20
pound per week uplift to universal
credit and working tax credit for 2021.
this has been a vital lifeline to
thousands of families in thanet
and provided an eight-figure cash
injection to their collective spending
power
helping them feed their children heat
their homes and support local business
it has helped contain the severe
pressure on the voluntary sector
including local food banks the estimated
cost of the uplift
is around two percent of the extra
government spending nationally triggered
by kobe 19
and even after it is taken into account
uk benefit payments are among the lowest
in europe
no part of kent will suffer more
detriment than fanny if this uplift is
taken away
nowhere in kent will more children
suffer more families go cold and hungry
and more local businesses lose out
the lives of residents already
struggling to manage will be made harder
this council will speak up for those in
urgent need
it calls on both valid mps to do the
same
council urges the chancellor to retain
the 20-pound uplift in his budget next
week
and not turn his back on the poorest
members of our community
it instructs the leader to write to him
tomorrow to express its deep concern
about the consequences of removing or
reducing this essential support
our members our constitution says that
motions must be about matters for which
the council has a responsibility
or which affect the district and surely
nobody looking at these figures could
question whether this matter affects our
district
or how significant this uplift is to the
lives of the residents in receipt of it
so it's absolutely right that we should
take council time to speak up for those
of our residents affected
and that we should expect both our local
mps to join us in pressing the
chancellor not to let them down
in next week's budget the impact of
poverty on our district
is substantial all tiers of government
have their part to play in tackling it
but it is important that this council
the part closest to the community calls
attentions to issues
that only affect a minority but do so
deeply
i give the government credit for many of
its financial interventions during the
pandemic
if not for some of the procurement
processes that he did
or didn't follow it turns out that the
magic monetary was there all along
but clearly the country's ability to
support businesses and individuals on
the present scale is time limited
and has consequences the 20 pound uplift
to universal credit is a tiny part of
the estimated 300 billion pound bill
for covid but the interesting thing
about it is that it was deemed necessary
at all
we know why the furlough scheme and
business grants were introduced
we know that many more people have been
pulled into universal universal credit
but if the scheme was adequate in the
first place then what was the need to
increase the amount
the answer of course is that universal
credit was never adequate
it was intended to make lives difficult
it imposed hard choices on people who
are not to blame for the circumstances
that oblige them to claim it what the
government realized i think
is that if a much larger cohort of
people were suddenly exposed to the
harsh reality
then there would be a political price to
pay uh councillor everett i think is
straying
quite away from the wording of the
motion i mean
i'm entitled to speak for the merchant
chair i believe
i well at this point if you could look
for a second or perhaps
well if you'd allow me to finish
explaining why i brought the motion i
think that won't take me very long
right okay then if you can wind up
shortly
so um let's not lose sight of the fact
that a third of our residents on
universal credit are in work
as newington wall councillor i see the
fantastic efforts by the team based at
the community centre
in keeping local people fed and i'm full
of praise for it
and we all know this is replicated in
other areas of planet but it's shameful
in my view that in this wealthy society
we force people to rely on charity to
feed their families
not just in the pandemic but at all it's
precisely the role of the state to
ensure that everyone has this most
fundamental level of support
how we do that in the longer term is the
subject for another day this motion is
not about the merits
or otherwise of universal credit as a
concept
nor am i arguing that the 20 pound
uplift is a panacea
local food banks are busy regardless of
it but it is clear that taking it away
would make the situation worse
this money doesn't sit in bank accounts
that is spent in our economy
if the uplift is taken away local shops
and businesses will lose out too
what's more as society comes out of
lockdown and the economy hopefully
recovers
the cost of the uplift will fall because
fewer people will be eligible
this motion is deliberately framed so
that every member of the council can
support it
but it is my view that the uplift should
be made permanent and that is just a
start to putting in place a proper
safety net
not not to provide that has always been
a political choice
the question tonight is which one of us
wants to take 20 pounds a week from the
pockets of our poorest residents
i hope that the answer to that is none i
move the motion
and i ask for a second thank you chair
thank you very much indeed uh councillor
everett uh for your motion
and for the supporting speech along with
uh went along with it
uh i presume you've got your second at
the hand i'll se connection
absolutely as counselor album thank you
very much encounter d counter album
now members should note that as only
council can adopt the motion on notice
the emotional
fall if the council does not agree to
debate it can i have a proposer and a
second
to debate the motion please do i have a
proposal
we debate this it's a very serious
matter i
[Music]
we think some feedback can i have a
second to please
right thank you if every member can
remember to switch off in micro once
they finish speaking
perhaps we can avoid the feedback right
okay
do members agree to debate the motion
i'm not hearing any words the contrary
and therefore we shall debate the motion
right would somebody like to lead please
have i got leaked
piper sorry for the interruption but i'm
actually looking lucky me i'm looking at
two pictures of councillor ara
and that will probably explain the
feedback when she was speaking
i think she's either on two separate
machines or has logged in twice
hence the noise sorry for the
interruption all right counselor piper
do you think that's the case counselor
aura
have you got two screens open or
something
if you have perhaps it might be an idea
to switch one off
saving any feedback right okay
uh discussing the motion this evening
i will do it i will do it counselor
right would you like to take off castle
yeah i wholeheartedly support this
motion
firstly i would like to thank tdc for
their kindness and support towards our
residents throughout the pandemic
also to our officers refuse collection
teams and
street cleaners for carrying out their
services
in this difficult time emphatic winter
shelter
for providing 24 7 accommodation for the
most vulnerable people in our society
than it is one of the
deprived area in the country as we all
know
i have experienced firsthand the
increase in numbers that have asked for
help from our food bank
i volunteered with the ramsgate
salvation army
and have heard so many heartbreaking
cases i have personally helped
residents with their heating bills the
pandemic has
damaged so many of our people
financially
physically and mentally that will stay
with them for a long time
if not forever i am deeply concerned
about those who suffer in silence
too embarrassed to ask for help or seek
donations
due to pride therefore i hope that the
whole house will support this motion
for the benefit of our residents thank
you
thank you councillor just to advise
everybody i've got a number of people
who will be speaking so far
uh we will be limiting to three minutes
each
so over to you counselor album
thank you chair i won't take up three
minutes uh it's just something this is
just
some important cheer for for
for our residents and you know i'm not
going to go into again what
what councillor everett has said because
he's absolutely spot on
um but if any of if any of us
as councillors can't see the need
for the continuation of this universal
credit for our 18 000 residents who are
who are using it um
then i'll i would just be ashamed of
this council chair
chairman i think it's vitally important
that we
do what we can as little as it may be
but
do what what we can to support our
residents
who need our help and i really really
hope that uh the government
uh in and uh mr sooner in his in his
presentation and budget on next week i
think
um actually continues this and looks to
try and make it a permanent thing
i mean with this government can waste 22
billion pound on a track and trace
system
given to its mates that doesn't actually
work
and yet are looking to take this away
from people
who who desperately need it so
i hope i really hope all members will
support this
this evening thank you chair thank you
council album that's well received
counselor ashby
thank you chair um whilst i
wholeheartedly agree that there is
a terrible situation with deprivation in
the area
what we must remember is that we should
be fighting for
for the residents of thanet or matters
that we can address
um i do feel that maybe this
developed into a little bit of a party
political broadcast but i will say
that um it is somewhat previous i think
we should
have assessed the situation and the mood
at the budget time which is not until
the end of march
it is believed that um
the chancellor will extend the universal
credit
uplift and because the conservative
government
understand the financial strain due to
the covet virus
has been the strain that has been put on
households
so it is understood that that is what it
will happen
so um there
is at this stage not need to
write to the chancellor you can
re-endorse it by that but it is
there is the understanding that he is
going to do this anyway
because he does understand the needs of
the eighteen thousand people in senior
but he also understands the needs of the
whole country and this is a national
issue
and that is what we need to be
bearing in mind we have local issues
that we should be addressing
so um i think that uh
maybe this is um a little bit of a wider
brief than what we're looking at here
we all agree that the 20 pounds uplift
is absolutely vital to the people of
thanet
and to the people of the whole country
that are in need at this time
so in on that basis i feel that we will
be abstaining from this because
we agree and it is already agreed that
it will be happening
thank you chair thank you very much
indeed councillor ashby
castle piper i have you next
thank you mr chairman um just echoing
really some of the things that
councillor ashby said um
and also something that uh counselor
everett mentioned in
in his words the number of claimants of
course
will naturally if that's the right word
forgive me if it isn't
it will fall after the pandemic is over
as people's lives begin to return
particularly from employment matters
back to
some kind of normal i would have to say
i fully support the decision by the
chancellor
which is being widely reported in all
the sensible newspapers
and indeed in the daily star that it
will be extended until the end of
september
so there is going to be at least
six more months from the end of march
when people can
be assured that that money will be
available i'm quite sure that the
government will take
everybody's views into account in terms
of
keeping that payment but certainly the
figures of money
involved are not going to be as big
as they are now because as our leader
mentioned the numbers of claimants will
fall in due course
but because of the nature of
the request to the mps to write
and get these things confirmed i will
support the motion this evening
thank you mr chairman thank you very
much indeed cancer piper
council curry
thank you chair um yeah even um
though this motion will ultimately be
one of many requests for the chancellor
to renew the 30 pound uplift to
universal credit
i really believe a decision to
permanently retain this relatively small
increase
would make a huge difference to all
fallen households who claim this benefit
around a third of these as others have
mentioned
are in work also i would imagine a large
proportion of this increase would be
spent within our local community
i fully support this motion and i hope
uh all members agree this is a positive
call from the leader of the council
thank you very much thank you very much
indeed
councillor yates i've got you down next
thank you chair um so i'm just going to
go through some
statistics as i think they're important
but before i do that i just want to
talk about the the duration of the
uplift and
i know it is mentioned in the press that
this will be a six month extension
um however like the the joseph um the
joseph roundtree foundation
actually expects unemployment to peak um
in autumn
in autumn of this year so having a six
month duration is just simply not
not good enough when unemployment is due
to peak
in autumn of 2021. um
so to statistics we've got over 18 000
claimants universal credit and working
tax credits
um we've got some the highest
unemployment in kent the highest youth
unemployment in the whole of the
southeast
our houses are some of the worst
insulated um
this money is expected to
if it continues would bring in 16
million pounds
a year into the finale economy to be
spent on local businesses
and buyer residents um so that's 20
pounds a week but it's a thousand pounds
a year per
claimant so this is this is big money
um and on to any potential argument
about um
we can't afford it this isn't this isn't
this isn't enough
um uk benefits um for unemployment as a
percentage of their previous income
is one of the lowest in europe uh only
17 percent um
and that's compared with the oecd
average of 64 percent of their previous
income
through their benefits so i i don't see
any good reason to justify this and as
cabinet member for
community wealth building um i think
we should all be keen to see as much
money coming into uh phanet as possible
and into our residents hands especially
during this pandemic
um so yeah i hope we all can support
this motion
thank you very much councillor yates and
for the statistics that's of course
always useful councillor wing
thank you thank you chair i could
actually scream i'm obviously not going
to
but this is long overdue my work puts
places me out in the community but and
also my role as a council of case work
in case work particularly around housing
and poverty
has been absolutely uh it's ongoing and
it's increased
if people need to realize that coastal
communities have a particular type of
deprivation
and i too i'm going to go into look at
some data and statistics
this is all readily available on kcc's
website there's a lot of stuff there and
i regularly look at this because i'm
presently in a role of putting an
application in to bring more money into
the area
47 of our walls are in the
poorest in kent 47 of our wards
of the of the poorest warden kent exist
in sanit planet
when we look at lower super output areas
that's a multiple index of deprivation
35 of those of
of those in kent exist in phanet
10 up 10 about those walls of those
lower
lower super output areas are actually in
the most deprived
if we look at the southeast region
average weekly wage it's 631 pounds
the average for workers in fannie is
517.
if you look at the average weekly salary
for a female
in in in than it drops to 350 pounds
child poverty is increased by 2 percent
37 percent
unemployment is at ten point two percent
is actually a rise of
ninety percent ninety point nine percent
since 2019
and youth unemployment is at sixteen
percent
we as a cabinet we as a group of people
as a council should be
shouting and screaming not only at kcc
because this data is there
it's on their website much of it is
increased or it stays the same and
nobody seems to be doing anything and we
need to be shouting at the government
that coastal communities like sanet need
extra
extra funding to get our communities
back on track
we are an area of deep deprivation deep
seated deprivation and we need to do
something about it so i fully support
this motion and thank you for bringing
it
rick thank you councillor wing
councillor towning thank you
uh this is clearly a political statement
been made by our leader
let's remind ourselves that this
conservative government
has gone beyond any other government in
peace times
to borrow money to support people
to support businesses and keep us
alive and if we're going to carry on
paying out large sums of money every
single day of the week
we are never going to be able to repair
it and who's going to bear that burden
of repayment
that burden the repayment is not down to
you and i
it's going to be our children our
grandchildren
and go on and on so we have got to
actually be able to cut our clock like
margaret thatcher used to say
got our clot accordingly so i would
never support this emotion
because it's purely a political matter
thank you
thank you councillor towning uh
councillor hopkinson
thank you chair um i just really want to
add my voice to uh supporting this
motion
um it's really clear from seeing
residents in my ward and and
and beyond that across stannet that
there's there's a seriously dire need
for this and i just want to refer back
to
what council ira said about you know
because this is something i've also seen
firsthand people do
feel shame and they are in desperate
situations and they do need us to be
speaking for them at the moment
um so i really want to add my voice to
this i also would like to just briefly
address the point that
okay it's good to hear that the reports
are that
uh the chance there will be will be
maintaining this 20 pound uplift
um but i want to address councillor
ashby's point that that's a reason to
abstain because i really
don't see uh the logic in that until
it's announced we don't know that the
the chancellor is going to do that for
sure
and also i don't know how we can be sure
that the chancellor in westminster
understands
what people in deprived areas like
ramsey and thanat need unless
their representatives like us are
speaking up for them so i really
strongly support this motion and i'm
really pleased it's being taken
to the council thank you very much
indeed councillor hopkinson
councillor jill bayford thank you chair
universal credit is a very complex
benefit
incorporating six others
i feel that the pandemic has changed
everything
people are in need of universal credit
who weren't before
nothing has been suggested to say that
this will end
until the need is it
is removed i feel that eventually there
will need to be
a complete review of the system to meet
the situation that people have found
themselves in
i therefore find this letter totally
unnecessary
um yes six months is what the
government are stating at the moment or
will be stating as we believe
but i strongly i'm strongly confident
that after that time
if if the uplift is needed um it will be
there
i don't think that a a blanket 20 pound
a week is necessarily correct
i think it would need to be addressed
according to the situation that people
find themselves in
after the pandemic thank you
thank you very much indeed casa bay for
councillor
thank you i apologize i missed
some of the other counselors and uh
speak
us i lost the connection and i was
waiting to get back in
and senate has go over 12
foot bank groups and distribution center
and as a volunteer with planet food link
i in one of the center i evidence
every week of about 20 families and
individuals
rely on a food bank and that
20 pound imagine how much affect
that individual and a family to have a
hot meal
on their table and not go to bed without
a hot meal
as a child grow up in their war zone and
go to bed without no
hot milk i feel for them and as i
arrived in this country the first
two months i was put in their
accommodation
with a group of people we were not
allowed to use a hot meal
so i still believe and i still
feel for those people how they go to bed
knowing their children cannot have a hot
meal or they cannot have himself
and they rely in the 21st century in
this country
on a food bank on a food distribution
and as a counselor in here
we need to think about those people we
need to support this motion
not only to keep this 20 pound
to get rid of of universal credit i am
surprised to see a council sitting here
to say
that we should government cannot afford
it we can afford to buy
bomb but you cannot afford feed our own
people
thank you thank you council ralph now
i've got the last speaker
now councillor whitehead
thank you chair we're here
as a council to represent our residents
that's our main job as a district
council
and
i've listened to the previous arguments
that obviously there are tiers of
government
obviously i'm aware that we have central
government we have county and we have
district
and in some people's minds those might
be separate
but the fact is that the ways that we
need to support
residents now during the pandemic are
very different
and without central funding directly
it's difficult for us as a district
council
to do what we need to for what was
already a very deprived
population our demographics in terms of
deprivation
are terrifying and over this pandemic
more and more people who've never had to
rely
on benefits in any form have had to come
into the system
and it's a system that's often confusing
it's a system that's often frightening
and i don't believe that this is a
political vote or a political choice
at this point because we know what's
right for our residents
and what's right for our residents is
that we
as a district council apply pressure to
our representatives
to make sure that the voices of our
residents are heard
at the highest possible level and i am
grateful
and i'm glad that the
people are very very convinced that this
will be extended in a way that will be
meaningful for our residents
and that will last long enough but we
need guarantees
of that for our residents and that
doesn't have to be a political vote
that's a vote based on what is right for
our area
and for our people and for our community
so please vote to help our residents
thank you
thank you very much councillor whitehead
now i've had very
varying views quite obviously about this
and therefore i do
need to turn to a vote from the chamber
this is not a recorded vote this is just
in order to discern intention of the
chamber
i shall therefore ask the deputy monitor
officer estelle culligan to go through
and ask for each person's particular
view as we go forward whether or not
this
uh should go to um agreement with motion
so um miss culligan can i turn to you to
go through a list of members
uh to get an idea of intention please
thanks very much chair uh good evening
members so i'll just go through
everybody's names
um councillor alban
yeah for the motion
councillor era for
councillor ashby abstain
councillor bailey for the motion
council of ambridge abstain
boyd
[Music]
for the motion
councilor curry for the motion
councillor dennis for the motion
councillor dexter
councillor dexter
abstain
thank you uh councillor duckworth
fourth motion thank you councillor
everett
all the motion council of france
for the motion
abstain
thank you council again abstain
councillor ghana four
councillor green
for the motion thank you councillor
gregory
very much for the motion
councillor heart abstain
counselor hopkinson for the motion
thank you councillor huxley for the
motion
uh councillor keane for the motion
councillor cup abstain
thank you um councillor pat moore
fall the motion councillor paul moore
abstain councillor ovindon
for the notion
councillor parsons abstain
um councillor stuart piper
for the motion
councilor potts
councillor potts
councillor pew abstain
counselor rat again i'm staying
counselor for
councillor rogers that's
abstain thank you councillor maeve
saunders
[Music]
councillor savage absolutely
councillor scoby for the motion
councillor scott abstain
councillor shrub of stone
councillor tomlinson abstain
councillor towning abstain
um councillor whitehead
for the motion
councillor wing for the motion with
bells on
councillor right abstain
thank you councillor yates four
so i believe chairman that's 25 4 and 24
abstentions
25 4 and 24 extensions
well therefore the motion is carried
and i presume
the letter will be put together to send
to the chancellor
for his consideration so thank you very
much indeed members
we shall now move on to agenda item nine
the leaders report
now as this meeting is entirely virtual
the leader's report has been circulated
to all members
and published on the council website i
therefore
call upon the leader uh to make a report
this evening leader
councillor everett
uh i think chair that um it's for uh
councillor ashby to comment on my report
since my report has been published
yes and you're quite right but i wonder
if you were going to say a few things
counselor ashby therefore can i turn to
you
thank you chair um and i apologize i'm
having some
um wi-fi issues this evening so
um if i lose my video link then um
i'll try and keep the audio running
so thank you chair i would like to pay
condolences and express my sadness on
the great loss of
camp councillor peter campbell for me
personally as a new counselor i learnt a
great deal
from peter even though i will admit at
first i found him a bit scary
my first committee sitting with peter
was overview and scrutiny in august 2015
i learned from him that we as
councillors have a duty to read and
understand our papers
and not be afraid to ask questions
one of my favorite memories of peter
will always be
that every year at full council agenda
item for members allowances he would
mischievously
raise a point of order and ask if we the
members should declare an interest
and every year the monitoring officer
would reply
that we were exempt maybe someone in the
labor group would like to keep that
traditional
going thank you for that point
our group also sends gary taylor our
best wishes for his retirement and thank
him for his contribution to the district
during his time as a councillor
i joined the leader in welcoming the
major reduction in the co
local covid virus infection rate
hopefully we are seeing the light at the
end of the tunnel but
we must not be led into a full sense of
security and now this he needs
virus to revisit us although it has been
a very very long 12 months
caution for a long while for a little
while longer will reward us
and and leave the term locked down as a
distant memory
we express our thanks and what should be
our never-ending gratitude to the
national health service and care staff
but also remember everyone on the front
line which includes the tdc
staff that for now on a year have kept
the services running through these very
difficult times
i would also like to thank the finance
team for the excellent work in getting
grant funds to over 1500 businesses in
the district
the manchester situation remains a
concern and it is disappointing that we
are not able
to halt the backsliding from what was
supposed to be a contingency site
into a full-blown component to the
country's goods and import
and export strategy i support suppose
it's um
it's unfortunate that the unnecessary
and avoidable delays to the reopening
and development of the airport
meant it was there for the taking the
sale of dreamland and removal of the
high risk to off
of our sorry and removal of the high fat
risk to our financial position
especially in the current economic
climate is not only the best solution
for the council
but also for the future of the park
giving it every chance to survive and
prosper once we emerge from the pandemic
perhaps the leader could confirm that
the delay on the sale caused by the
labour council's demand for additional
valuations didn't have a negative
impact on the sale value of seven
million pounds
the idea of replicating the project
model
used for the margate town deal for
maximizing the benefit
to ramsgate following the provisional
award of 2.7 million through the
future high street fund will be
effective if all local groups are
engaged
with it is essential that ideas and
research that has already been
undertaken
are collated and utilized in the project
bringing the port study into the
framework makes perfect sense to enable
joined up thinking and underpins the
whole process of both the port and
harbour
alongside the higher street retail and
leisure facilities
for economic regeneration
i can't agree with your statement that
the old model of
evening public meetings in the community
is of limited use
the principles of full democratic
process are based on access for all
if we can learn anything from the
hanford parish council zoom debacle
simply transferring traditional meetings
onto online video platforms is certainly
not enough to encourage democratic
dialogue or to avoid providing tools
that favor the loudest or aggressive
person
thus making it easier to create
opposition than consensus
do we really want to end up as
stay-at-home keyboarders
i am concerned that a major shift in
thinking to all things online
being the way forward at council
committee meetings or public engagement
is steering us away from being more
engaged from there is
with the residents of thanet this is
highlighted by the cabinet's proposal to
charge an administration fee to
residents who wish to submit comments to
tdc
on planning matters either by email or
writing which are deemed long or complex
responses
rather than using the online
consultation portal to which our group
are strongly opposed and i request it is
removed from the sci
however i can agree there is a practical
sense using video software for certain
elements like training and members
briefings
but i certainly believe that for our
main activities life physical
engagement should never be lost at
council or indeed government
it doesn't have to be either or a hybrid
solution is the future
therefore i request a leader to
seriously consider for us to return to
the chamber at the next full council
meeting
with a mixed solution of maybe the chair
the cabinet and shadow along with main
committee chairs and a percentage of
members
with the balance of members joining from
home via video link
at the old time of 7 p.m thank you
thank you very much indeed casper ashby
in fact i could endorse that for my part
i would very much welcome the
opportunity to return
for full council to the chamber um and
it's something i have been discussing
with
um the head of democratic services uh
the possibility of the hybrid meeting
uh councillor um everett would you like
to respond cash to ashby thank you
yes i would and i think um i'll just
deal with the dreamland point first of
all
i mean i think everybody's been involved
with dreamland and and the recent style
of it would know that it is an
exceptionally complicated matter
um i'm i'm grateful and i think it was
probably councillor campbell actually
who wanted two
valuations i can't quite remember but
certainly he was part of um
he was he was interested in that subject
and i don't
the fact that we saw two valuations
certainly had no influence on the time
scale at all
um it's just a very complicated process
um but thankfully we reached the end of
it um i think the whole
this whole subject of um online
interaction is very interesting one
um as far as the council meetings are
because i don't think that's a matter
for me as leader
um i think that's a matter for the chair
of council and for um
for the whole council to consider um
obviously as soon as it's safe to be
back in the council chamber i would
welcome that and um
i think we also have to look at what the
law says um the law doesn't allow us at
the moment to have meetings after i
think about may the seventh which are
held virtually at
all um nobody could then participate i
think the law is likely to be changed in
the next uh
the next few weeks and months um
i'm in favor of getting back to the
council chamber but i'm also in favor of
making the best use of technology and i
think that what we're
talking about in terms of public
engagement is building on the success
that we've seen
in engaging with members online um
more people come to our online briefings
than ever came to the briefings in the
council chamber
i'm sure that's also true in the
community it doesn't mean that we
wouldn't have public meetings
it just means that we have to recognize
a lot of people don't feel safe going
out in the evening don't want to go out
in the evening
and don't come to those meetings anymore
except on particular topics and i accept
that there are exceptions
but i think the answer is a mixture i
absolutely agree
and i'm not suggesting anything
otherwise i'm a bit puzzled by this
sudden focus from councillor ashby on
the um
the administration fee in the um
statement of community involvement
because when it came to count when it
came to cabinet
nobody from the conservative group had
anything to say whatsoever and it was
only after when it appeared on a blog
site somewhere that the conservative
group started taking an interest in it
so i don't know whether they
hadn't had the chance to read the report
before the meeting or what
um obviously it's a consultation um and
we will
we will take notice of the response we
get in the consultation no decision has
been taken
um but it's a very minor matter which
would affect very few people um
and we'd have to look at what the
dimensions of that
but i can assure you that there's no
attempt going on here to make it more
difficult for people to contribute their
opinions
thank you thank you very much indeed
councillor everett um just to clarify
against what i said earlier i would not
ever endorse going against the law
merely my enthusiasm as chair to
reconvene
uh in the chamber at uh tdc as
and as when legally possible so thank
you very much moving on to the
councillor reverend piper
thank you mr chairman leader thank you
for your report
much of it as always is factual and very
informative
and gives us some insight into the the
hard work that not only you
but also and especially the members of
staff
and the officers of the council so
i just really want to say that i think
staff
and officers deserve our continuing
full support as members and we all know
that most
areas that we need to be addressed are
addressed
and usually more directly without
actually coming through
the formalities of a full council
meeting
unless it's absolutely necessary
and i think it's good for the public to
know that the members have
real support and encouragement for
uh off senior officers and all their
staff uh thank
covet numbers are thankfully very low
now around about 70
as opposed to about 570 per hundred
thousand
just a few uh months ago just a couple
of months ago
um i i think we need to continue to
encourage
uh people whom we represent that
whatever its failings might be
broadly speaking the lockdown and the
vaccination program and testing programs
have worked and personally i don't
make any distinction between which
political group is in power
i think the current government have
worked exceptionally hard
and we have we are evidence of the fact
that it
is working it has failings but it is
working
tdc communication with the public i
think has
improved immensely over the last 12
months
with regular bulletins and things being
published on social media platforms
and uh that has resulted i think and i
hope it will continue to insulting a lot
more
uh interaction with members so i would
say uh
long may that continue
i didn't mention uh separately a matter
of the late peter campbell because i
knew it was there was a comment about
his service
uh in your report and of course we
as a group but certainly myself as an
individual having the opportunity
uh to respond to your report uh would
want to endorse everything that's been
said
about peter as a man mr chairman i hope
in responding to uh the leader's report
and his comments about
uh peter campbell you won't mind
if i pick up on his comment that he
joined the council from 2007
so he's been a councillor from 2007
then we have a little dash to 2021
and there is a small very short piece of
work written by linda ellis
in 1996 and it's simply called
the dash i would like with your
indulgence to share it it's just a few
lines
i read of a man who took to speak at the
funeral of a friend he referred to the
dates on the tombstone
from the beginning to the end
he said what mattered most of all was
the dash
between the years for peter
the dash today is a period of service
it's a length of time but linda alice
goes on to write
about it matters not
as people how much we own
the cars the house the cash
what matters for us as councillors and i
believe we can all
learn something from the late peter
campbell
what matters to us as councillors
is how we live and serve
during that dash
thank you mr chen thank you very much
indeed for that
uh councillor piper and i would endorse
that myself
i've always been firmly of the opinion
that to be a councillor
is an act of service leader oh to you
uh yeah uh thank you councillor piper
and as we might expect obviously you
speak very well in these circumstances
because i think you have some experience
of of reflecting on
on the end of people's lives one thing
we haven't said about councillor
campbell is how brave he was in the face
of
his impending death um and i certainly
you know it certainly made it made a
great impression on me
um i i welcome your comments about the
staff counselor piper
um i think our senior officers and our
all our officers in fact are performing
admirably in difficult circumstances
um we've got used to this remote working
but it's
um it's still strange um i look forward
to being able to meet more of them face
to face as i'm sure
members do across the council and i i
don't denigrate their service when i
talk about the magnificent service of
the staff in the nhs
um i think we all know the nhs are a bit
special but our staff
have done very well and yeah i would
agree about the vaccination program
i'm just waiting for my appointment
thank you very much indeed leader uh
counselor ghana
are you ready to comment on the leaders
report i am chair thank you very much
um and like the others i'd also like to
start by joining the leader and everyone
else
in expressing my sadness at the death
last week of
peter campbell being a relative newcomer
i didn't have the opportunity to get to
know him well
but i certainly appreciated the
knowledge and experience he brought to
committee meetings i sat on with him
and as mentioned his willingness to
challenge and ask questions
it's certainly something we can all look
to do more of
it's also sad that councillor gary
taylor has decided to stand down another
whose contributions will be met
though i'm sure he'll remain as active
within the wider community
as he was as a councillor as we start
taking the first steps towards reopening
society
i'd also once again like to join the
leader in thanking all frontline workers
across spanish
for their hard work keeping us all safe
and to especially thank all council
employees
who continue to maintain essential
services during these difficult times
including the recent spell of bad
weather
the leader has highlighted how the
mismanagement of the easing of last
year's lockdown
caused a number of issues with the
sudden influx of visitors
to the isle we recognize that a number
of officers have been working hard to
prepare for the coming summer
and have welcomed the engagement at the
recent member briefing
to discuss the new public safety
protection order
of which we are generally supportive of
course
the success of this pspo will not just
be dependent on how well it is
communicated
but also on how effectively it is
enforced
one of our particular concerns is the
adverse impact
that the growing number of jet skis has
had on the coastline
and its wildlife particularly in waters
adjacent to major seedbird
breeding colonies which also affects our
common and grey seal populations
we would urge them that more thought is
given
to making sure provision is made for
their protection
as a leader mentions manson has remained
in the news for one reason or another
it does indeed seem as if like many
other government plans
there is no clear path to the ending of
the temporary use of manston
as either a covid testing facility or as
a lorry holding area
the impact on the surrounding villages
may indeed have been less than expected
and we hope it stays that way as for
part 73 of the dco saga
we of course welcome the fact that the
secretary of state has
had to go back to the drawing board on
this not only was his analysis of the
need for the development flawed
his decision inadequately reasoned and
procedural safeguards prescribed in the
infrastructure planning rules breached
he failed to discharge his duty to meet
carbon emissions targets under section
one
of the climate change act 2008
it's time for the secretary of state and
others to finally accept
that the inspectors in their wisdom and
after a full examination of the evidence
were right and there is no case for
reopening the airport
we also have to say that we have been
shocked to hear recent comments from one
of our mps
and others sharing environmental
concerns about excessive development on
their patches
counselor ghana can we stick to uh the
leaders report
please i'm just covering the manchester
issue that he um
he brought up um just that their
champion
of the airport in the first place made
these developments of fate accompli
we welcome the provisional award of 2.7
million through the future high street
fund
and share the disappointment that the
government has only awarded 69
of the original bid we know that there
are difficult decisions to make
and hope that the local groups and
residents who worked hard to prepare the
bid
in the first place with
are fully engaged throughout the process
as i'm sure the leader is aware
local ramsgate residents are also
concerned that the port consultation
seems to be being rolled it
up into the wider landscape consultation
which some think may end up with it
being downplayed or shelved
or information not being available to
residents about what's happening
with it with them but
there's massive potential at the port
but at present it's losing money on a
daily basis so we urgently need a plan
for it
particularly with the council's finances
as tight as they are
to finish off we welcome the leaders
commitment to enable better
communication
with the wider community of than it
as he knows we as a group favor a more
open and transparent way of working
so that the residents who elect us are
able to see and understand
how and why decisions are made we
recognize that there is indeed a lot of
misinformation out there
and believe that the best way to tackle
this is to make sure we
as a council not only share as much
factual information as possible
but also engage with the wider community
in regular public forums
including old-style face-to-face
meetings once they're allowed again
there's huge enthusiasm and talent in
planet and very many groups concerned
with improving things in our communities
who we need to be listening to thank you
thank you council ghana council everett
back to you
yeah thank you councillor garner and um
just on this on this issue of public
engagement i think that
um we will know that there are certainly
motive topics the airport is one
um probably the portland harbour is
another room which is quite possible to
have a large public meeting
but i think there's a lot more that we
can share with our residents
for example about the pspos perhaps but
we can do
online and that would they are more
likely to participate and they're more
likely to watch the meeting on on
youtube or they're more likely
to join the meeting and ask questions
online than they are actually to go to a
public meeting
um to go out of their ways out of their
homes spend time in their evening
traveling traveling battles and forwards
so this and this is just about improving
accessibility it's not about a
replacement strategy so
yes more engagement use both routes but
certainly
we need to do some experimenting and we
need to present to the public who we
actually are
rather than the caricatures that we're
sometimes presented as
um and sometimes we present each other
as let's let's be honest for political
purposes
um in terms of jet skis i mean this was
extensively discussed at the members
briefing and i thought that there was a
a good range of opinion there including
some councillors who spoke up on behalf
of water users
and that was interesting as well um i'm
not personally a fan of jet skis i've
made that pretty clear
in the past um but the the the
the effect of the pspos and the
intention of the pspos
is to better manage jet skis we're
actually taking out some sites that they
can currently be reduced
currently be launched from and i
absolutely agree about enforcement but
enforcement
isn't just about a big stick approach
it's also about
educating people and it's also about
bringing people along with
you so there's a lot of work to be done
in that area
and we will be talking about the pspos
again at cabinet i think on march the
18th
and i hope that members will come along
and have their say there because we
would welcome their input as indeed we
did those who were at the briefing
and i think that's it thank you thank
you very much indeed leader
that covers the leader reporting agenda
item nine um
moving on to agenda item 10 the report
of the chairman of the ovu and scrutiny
panel
i call upon castle bayford to present
the report
thank you chairman um it's impossible
to use the word scrutiny on cdc without
mentioning peter campbell and i make
absolutely no apologies for doing so
um i hope i won't repeat what's been
said and i won't say very much but i
think it's important to know that peter
was on
scrutiny from 2007
right the way through till his death
and for the last six years was chair or
vice chair of that committee
points already been made that he'd
always read his papers thoroughly
it was very well informed whenever he
signed up at a meeting
he was a tough inquisitor but always
very fair
no disrespect to councillor curry but
i'm afraid that i feel that as far as
scrutiny is concerned
peter campbell was irreplaceable it was
the embodiment
of the cliche of someone who takes their
task seriously
but never takes themselves too seriously
i've been on this council an awful lot
of years and i've seen a lot of good
counsellors
but peter was simply one of the best and
i've got to say that as far as i'm
concerned
it was an absolute privilege to work
with him when i nearly forgot
i asked members to note the report thank
you
thank you very much indeed counselor
paper now he's come all the way from
kingsgate for this do members have any
comment on his report at all
i'm not here i've got one hand up from
councillor ashby
you've got a hand up counselor ashby do
you wish to say something
uh sorry chair i think that was a from a
previous uh
agenda item although i really relish
speaking to councillor bayford on this
particular occasion i
i don't have anything to to add sorry
okay
mutual appreciation here right thank you
very much indeed councillor bayford
moving on to agenda item 11
council tax resolution 2021-2022
uh members will have received a
supplementary agenda today
it's only quite minor i'd revise that in
accordance with council procedure rule
17.6 i will call for recorded vote on
the motion
or any amendment substantive emotions
that may arrive
i will now ask the cabinet member for
finance administration community wealth
building council yet to present the
report councillor yates would you like
to present your report please
yes please thank you chair um so as you
say
as a result of some last-minute
adjustments to facilitate council tax
billing
there have been a number of rounding
changes made to the originally published
report
these have been highlighted in yellow
within the report but for reference
these are
on table 4 the kent police and crime
commissioner
band f has been increased one pence from
315 pounds and 10 pence to 315 pounds
and 11 pence
and on table 5 band f each parish figure
is increased by two bents
this is a statutory report presented in
a prescribed format
now that preceptors have set their
precepts council can resolve council tax
forthanic residents from 2021 to 2022.
the preceptors are kent county council
kent fire and rescue
the kent police and crime commissioner
and the parish and town councils
the focus of this report is the request
for members to approve
than its element of the council tax for
2021 to 2022
however in reality there's no room for
variation from the proposed
presented in the report the real
business and hard work of the budget
setting process
was conducted at council two weeks ago
when members agreed our budget
the budget is predicated on the council
tax increase that is presented in the
report
and due to the constraints that this
government continues to place on locally
elected members we cannot consider any
further increase
without subjecting a proposal to a local
referendum
in terms of our increase for next year i
draw members attention to table 6 at the
end of the report
as stated above the 4 pound 99 increase
is the maximum permitted but even with
this restriction
this shows that our 2.1 increase is once
again
one of the lowest increases of all
public bodies as district councils have
not been
afforded the same flexibility to
consider tax increases as the 5
increase for counties or 15 pounds for
the police
following kcc's recent announcement to
allocate funding for a
pound hardship payment for residents
eligible for the council tax support
tdc officers and civica colleagues have
worked hard to ensure that these
measures are in place
and i'm pleased to confirm tonight that
residents
will benefit from this 50 pound discount
immediately
rather than having to wait for it to be
applied retrospectively
on top of having one of the most
generous council tax support schemes in
the county
this additional discount will help
protect the most vulnerable even further
in these uncertain times
i move the recommendations thank you
council yates uh do you have a second
ready
seconder please our second next year
councillor album
councillor alvin is seconding thank you
very much indeed do i have anybody who
wishes to speak
well we will now begin a recorded vote
just to remind the recommendations
that members approve the finance
district council element of the council
tax charge is set out in the report
that members approve the determination
of section one of this report
can i move therefore to uh the deputy
monitoring officer
mr culligan to carry out um the recorded
vote ms culligan
thanks very much chair so councillors
i'll go through everybody's name
again and if you just say um with it in
favor against or abstain thank you
so um councillor alban four councillora
paul councillor ashby
four councillor bailey
for councillor bambridge
four councillor jill bayford
four councillor robert bayford
four councillor boyd
yeah thank you sorry there was a bit of
an echo
councillor crittenden in favor
councillor curry four
councillor dennis four
counselor dexter four
councillor duckworth four
councillor everett four
councillor farence four
council of fellows four
councillor game four
councillor ghana four
councillor green four
thank you councillor gregory paul
councillor hart four
councillor hopkinson
four thank you
councillor huxley or
councillor keem four
councillor cup four
thank you councillor pat moore four
councillor paul moore four
councillor ovindon
councillor parsons four
councillor stuart pipe huh
paul your councillor potts
i don't think councillor potts is here
councillor pugh
four thank you councillor
again for
councillor raw four
[Music]
councillor rogers four
councillor roper four
councillor zeki four
councillor david saunders four
councillor maeve saunders
councillor savage four
councillor scoby four
councillor scott four
councillor shrub four
councillor tomlinson four
councillor towning four
whitehead four
right okay thank you councillor potts
um councillor right four
and councillor yates four
thank you um chair that's unanimous and
it's 54.
thank you very much thank you very much
everybody
agenda item 12 our last agenda item this
evening changes to representatives on
outside bodies now the recommendations
are to agree the following two changes
the remainder of the 20 20 21 year
number one that councillor boyd replaces
councillor cup on the young people's
partnership
conversation number two that councillor
ovenden replaces
councillor huxley on the sandwich and
peggle bay national
nature reserve steering group i knew
that the recommendation should be
detailed below be agreed with the vice
chairman please second
second mr chairman now unless anyone
objects the recommendation i take them
as agreed
is everybody in agreement
and i don't see any difficulty here at
all so that therefore is agreed thank
you
members thank you very much indeed for
your attendance this evening that
concludes the business of the meeting of
the council
thank you very much indeed